hier en parlant de football françois
rebsamen une montée cette année
vous aimeriez oui bien sûr sûr sûr c'est
un moment formidable pour une ville de
montée en ligue 1 on a une très belle
équipe cette année elle joue et je joue
bien au football et en plus on a un
président qui fait les choses
sérieusement une bonne oui j'y crois
on le disait vous êtes revenu à la fin
de l'été à la mairie de dijon votre
premier conseil municipal depuis votre
retour c'était ce lundi
l'opposition ne vous a pas ménagés vous
avez repris vos habitudes les uns et les
autres au delà de ça est ce qu a pas un
risque quand on a été maire 13 ans qu'on
a été ministre
finalement d'être vite agacé et de
d'exercer le pouvoir avec une forme
d'autorité que peut-être on dénonçait
quand on était soit même dans
l'opposition vous êtes conscient de ce
risque là de la durée de l'image que les
gens ont de vous parce que vous avez été
ministre
bien sûr de sûr mais je crois d'abord un
premièrement parce que je le ressens
j'entends que les dijonnais sont
contents de me voir revenir les messages
de sympathie d'amitié de du retour et et
m'ont aidé et je le dis je les remercie
tous ses messages tous ces gens dans la
rue qui me dit c'est bien que vous soyez
revenu et tout ça fait plaisir mais moi
vous dites m'ont aidé parce que parce
que c'était pas facile parce que j'ai
perdu un ami parce que voilà parce que
ce mois d'août a été mentionné lmnp très
compliqué pour moi voilà parce que
quitter ce ministère n'était pas facile
non plus parce que je voulais aller au
bout de cette tâche est donc c'est une
forme des de soutien oui que j'ai reçu
de des dijonnaises des dijonnais et puis
non parce que vous savez c'est s'il ya
tellement de choses à faire encore c'est
ce que j'allais vous demandez vous êtes
maire depuis 2001 on sait que la ville
de dijon a été profondément transformé
ce qui restera à faire ce qu'il faut pas
donner les rênes à quelqu'un d'autre
corps à d'autres idées mais ça viendra
viendra le moment venu ça viendra mais
j'avais dit je ferai deux ou trois
mandats je crois quand j'ai été élu
03/06 encore des grands projets à porter
et y en a encore mais je voudrais
répondre à votre question d'abord vos
propre à l'évacuer sur l'autorité g de
l'autorité mais je ne fais pas preuve
d'autoritarisme
c'est la différence et l'autorité ça va
de pair avec le respect je respecte
l'opposition mais je demande à être
respecté et j'ai regretté des
comportements que j'ai pu voir dans les
retransmissions si vous voulez on pourra
en parler dans les retransmissions du
conseil municipal la manière dont
l'opposition se comportait avec alamillo
est avec moi on se comporte pas comme ça
je voudrais le dire clairement
donc je respecte l'opposition elle doit
me respecter et le respect ça passe par
le respect des électeurs par le temps de
parole le maîtriser et caetera et par
des propos et par des propos qui doivent
être tenus en conformité avec la
responsabilité que confère le fait
d'être conseiller municipal donc
donc voilà j'ai dit les choses comme ça
mais non non je confonds pas au
contraire si je peux développer
démocratie au sgg appelé éventuellement
je vais le voir je vais prendre
rendez-vous et elano du grès c'était la
question suivante chez visa no du grès
pour les opinions qui nous regardent
c'est un chef d'entreprise dijonnais qui
avait mené une liste aux municipales qui
avaient un peu créé la surprise qui
avait attiré pas mal d'électeurs mais je
vois je vois qu'il est de temps en temps
elle a des idées vous savez j'ai parlé
par exemple que ces municipales de
street art l'art de la rue et donc j'ai
vu qu'il avait mis sur internet postée
sur twitter
ddd image de ce que pouvait faire de ce
qu'on pouvait faire un dut street a donc
je me dis c'est bien géré twitté ça et
donc parce que je pense que c'est bien
et s'il veut par vous allez proposer
quoi une émission je vais lui proposer
de participer et il le fera en toute
indépendance qui le qu'il le veuille ou
qu'ils veuillent pas c'est pas pour
l'empêcher de se présenter aux
municipales
vous savez mais il ya papa vous mais bon
c'est loin c'est dans cinq ans il ya
tellement de choses à faire
moi je suis là encore pour 5 ans minimum
donc voilà je suis là donc il faut que
l'opposition se disent bas et il faut
faire avec vous repartirez pas au
ministère mais je repartirai pas au
mister non le joueur pas pourquoi alors
vous parlez de la période des cinq
enfants crever oui ça quand je suis là
je suis je suis maire j'assume je suis
président de la communauté urbaine un
mot justement pardonnez moi de vous
couper mais c'est un à millau qui a mené
ce dossier dijon le grand dijon est une
communauté urbaine ça change quoi
il nous reste huit minutes donc on a
beaucoup de choses à dire mais
rapidement pour les deux cent cinquante
trois mille habitants du grand dijon
eh bien il ya plus de communauté de
destin on a renforcé la communauté de
destin de ces communes elles sont plus
liés dans leur fonctionnement dans leur
histoire leurs compétences et donc par
exemple la compétence voirie et
maintenant assumé par la communauté
urbaine
c'est à dire qu'on met en moyenne
ensemble les moyens de ces communes pour
faire face aux difficultés de l'époque
et donc c'est je pense quelque chose de
tout à fait enrichissant et je suis très
heureux que ça rapporte plus d'argent de
l'état oui en dotation oui c'était aussi
un calcul que j'avais fait ça à éviter
d'être frappés des baisses de dotations
puisque on a augmenté notre dgf par ce
transfert pression de mon général de
fonctionnement dotation générale de
fonctionnement qui frappe durement je
dois le dire les collectivités locales
voyez je le dis qui frappe durement et
dijon est extrêmement fragilisée par
cette baisse des dotations globales de
fonctionnement gens ne fait que vous et
en même temps vous en prenez acte ou pas
on sait que l'état essaie de faire des
économies donc moins donner aux villes
c'est normal de recoins de vue ou bien
sûr c'est normal des manifestations
demers et c'est vrai mais je me suis je
ne suis pas descendu dans la rue mais je
soutiens cette démarche de dire pas trop
trop vite
évidemment il faut faire des efforts et
nous les faisons mais il ya des
inégalités de ce trac
ça mériterait disons que la dotation
globale de fonctionnement est très
différente d'une ville à une autre pour
vous donnez vite un exemple à dijon elle
est on simplifie de 200 euros par
habitant à levallois perret chez
monsieur balkany
ll 660 euros par habitant voilà la
réalité donc il faut ramener de la
justice entre les collectivités locales
on passe on essaye rapidement vu
quelques grands dossiers les climats de
bourgogne en a beaucoup parlé de la
vigne ça a été un grand plaisir pour
beaucoup de monde
on a peut dire que le centre ville de
dijon était aussi inscrit au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
et vous savez que
on a peu dim et c'est tant mieux pour
parce que après tout les idées il faut
qu'elles progressent tout seul il ya
toujours des gens pour y porter mais il
ya en 2002 2003 j'ai dit je veux
inscrire des gens au patrimoine mondial
de l'unesco
et pour le faire il fallait monter ce
projet et nous l'avons monté mais je
suis très fier très fier pour dijon
c'est une tellement belle ville qu'elle
son patrimoine historique c'était les
102 ha du secteur sauvegardé sont
classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité ça en les dijonnais fiers de
leur ville encore plus et il l'était
déjà
et donc on va prendre des mesures pour
le faire savoir parce que c'est bien de
le savoir mais c'est encore mieux de le
faire savoir et donc il faut absolument
que nous communiquions sur ce dossier
sur ce sujet pas uniquement sur le
centre ville de dijon mais aussi sur
l'ensemble
vous savez que la cité de la gastronomie
va être km premiers sujets suivants
c'est le sujet du livre le premier
kilomètre premier de la route des vins
donc vaut un grand projet il ya des
grands projets assez pour l'instant est
à ses débuts
ça va se faire ça un vrai intérêt pour
les dijonnais oui c'est clair
c'est clair c'est un développement comme
le musée des beaux-arts c'est c'est la
ville qui se montre aux autres aux
étrangers c'est le tourisme c'est le
développement économique
c'est une ville qui est ouverte c'est
une ville qui est européenne les
dijonnais ont voté oui je m'étais engagé
pour le processus européen
ici donc on a une ville avec des
habitants qui qui sont qui doivent
rayonner l'attractivité de dijon est
renforcée de la communauté urbaine
et puis ce chemin le long des des vignes
des coteaux de 2
de nuits-saint-georges et et de bonnes
et la ville de beaune
c'est vraiment magnifique et en même
temps bronn aussi lancé le projet d'une
cité du vin tant mieux c'est bon on se
dirige pas vers un joli gâchis avec de
citer une gamme chez nous on est
labellisé le site et de la gastronomie
boon avait essayé de l'être bonne
n'avait pas été retenu c'est une petite
ville bonne c'est une jolie ville c'est
une petite ville je veux dire une ville
qui fait vingt mille habitants
l'agglomération digérer ces deux cent
cinquante trois mille habitants donc
laissé c'est comme un quartier de dijon
doit dire sur la cité de la gastronomie
polémique a rebondi cette semaine avec
les syndicats de l'hôpital qui estime
que l'achat des terrains va pas
rapporter assez à l'hôpital la société
cgr qui elle aussi était candidate sur
ce projet compte est elle aussi votre
choix
quelle réaction vous avez là dessus est
il vrai que ça aurait pu être vendus
plus chers et rapporter plus d'argent à
l'hôpital seraient peut être encore
vendu plus cher et encore plus cher et
encore plus cher ça dépend ce qu'on veut
faire de la ville d'abord il faut
respecter le plan d'urbanisme et donc le
projet de monsieur cgr n'était pas
conforme au plan d'urbanisme et donc il
aurait fallu le revoir à la baisse et
aller devant la justice pour contester
votre oeil on verra ce que dira ce que
dira la justice ça c'est autre chose
mais j'ai rencontré dans son
organisation syndicale
je crois les avoir convaincus j'ai porté
l'intérêt de l'hôpital général du chu
pendant suffisamment longtemps pour
avoir obtenu des aides de tous les
ministres qui se sont succédé à porter
l'image du chu du chu françois
mitterrand c'est une belle image est ce
que leur propose la ville à travers la
cité de la gastronomie le chu ne le
trouvera avec aucune aux propositions
expliqué aux bourguignons qui nous
regardent qui connaissent pas le sujet
c'est qu'effectivement il ya un
transfert d'hôpital et qui rentre dans
le dossier de la base d'un compromis
c'est pour ça qu'on parle d'hôpital en
même temps que la cité d'agde à ce mois
là bas il faut savoir que il faut des
amiantés
c'est compliqué il faut dépolluer voilà
c'est un hôpital général il suffit de
voir l'étude de liga sur le patrimoine
que laissent les hôpitaux quand il sent
bon donc il ya beaucoup de travail à
faire
c'est un dossier très compliqué mais
c'est un dossier formidable pour la
ville de dijon dijon va être parce que
c'est son histoire une grande cité de la
gastronomie va attirer des des touristes
de tous les pays de la terre et donc
voilà on va le porter c'est difficile au
début il ya aucune volonté de léser le
chu la cfdt quel syndicat majoritaire le
sait bien j'ai essayé de convaincre la
cgt je vais y arriver
enfin franchement vous savez aujourd'hui
le gardiennage du sud il coûte 400 mille
euros 500 mille euros rien que reçu en
dépenses de fonctionnement donc plus
vite ça sera fait je crois que c'est ça
la demande des organisations syndicales
plus vite ça sera fait et et mieux ce
sera pour le chu il nous reste deux
minutes trente démission mais un petit
mot tout de même sur quelque chose qui
concerne le maire que vous êtes c'est
aussi le dossier des migrants
on se souvient de position plutôt ferme
que vous aviez prison se rappelle par
exemple du squat de l'école des greffes
à dijon ou sur le dossier des roms aussi
à l'époque
vous avez annoncé que la ville pouvait
accueillir plusieurs dizaines de
familles quelle est votre position
l'hérault 30 et 50 contre 30 et 50
il faut que la ville accueille mais il
ya déjà beaucoup d'autres cas à régler
un certain nombre de squat à dijon avec
des migrants
que doit faire le maire là dessus mais
alors là on est interrogé par l'état il
s'agit de réfugiés et cette image non
pas uniquement celle de l'enfant mais de
ces dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui fuient les atrocités de la guerre
qu'on voit sur les routes de l'europe ne
peut pas laisser un homme un humain
indifférent mais enfin où est ton l'art
et les gens qui étaient là ya deux ans
et est déjà aussi des gens qui fuyaient
ces situations là et ils sont pour
certains toujours là mais là c'est pas
le même statut
ceux qui partaient ils sont soit des
des des gens qui viennent pour des
raisons économiques la zone économique à
ce moment là ils sont les demandes de
droit d'asile
on vérifie si la réalité leur permettent
d'avoir s'ils ne répondent pas aux
critères du droit d'asile ils doivent
être expulsés retourner dans leur pays
c'est voilà c'est ça être ferme
mais si l'on 6 obtiennent l'asile
alors la france doit les accueillir et
quand ils ont le statut de réfugié et
ceux qui viennent là où qui viendront
qui viendraient on ne sait pas bien ces
syriens notamment ils ont le statut de
réfugié et au doit accueillir des
réfugiés
voilà en nombre respectable pour un pas
désorganiser faire chuter ben on a
recensé vous dire on a recensé ce qu'ils
en avaient comme place dans nos
résidences sociales et on a entre 30 et
50 places disponibles donc je les fait
savoir au gouvernement
voilà merci françois rebsamen qui
l'aurait c'est en revue votre activité
au ministère et puis votre retour
et il ya le musée des beaux-arts et ça
fait partie des projets moelleux des
cinq ans à venir c'est donc la fin de
cette volée libre merci donc en soirée
sa mère d'être venu nous voir samedi
prochain vol libre spécial élections
régionales on en a peu parlé mais ça va
beaucoup nous occuper dans les semaines
à venir élections en bourgogne franche
comté à partir de 11 heures avec un
débat avec les principales têtes de
liste ne le manquez pas surtout mon
week-end au revoir et merci